what does your investment portfolio look
like is it all real estate or d of other
assets i some crypto i don't understand
it but a lot of
a lot of really smart people do and i
i'm i i understand that i have i have 24
hours a day of life and i have so much
brain power that i can devote to so many
things i punt in a lot of areas like i'm
gonna get good at what i'm good at and
i'm gonna trust other smart people in a
lot of other areas so yeah a couple
hundred grand of crypto some equities i
i love apple i can't really talk about
stocks on here this is not a
recommendation i personally like apple
facebook google and microsoft i don't
think there's four companies that are
better than those and get investing
outside of that right now is is a waste
of money do you buy uh indexes or you
just buy the four i buy those stocks
yeah that's four and how do you think
about um every month when you get cash
flow in you're like okay i need x
dollars for expenses and the rest goes
to investing or do you have like uh do
you think of like um like a rainy day
fund just just yeah and
numbers aren't as important as just like
how do you conceptually think about as
cash flow comes in uh in terms of a lot
of people i think are like okay cool
this all sounds awesome but like what do
i tactically do and everybody's
situation is different but i think that
the concept of uh you gotta pay your
expenses right um you should have some
sort of like cash fund or or emergency
fund and then everything else like it's
just i think of it as like a savings
account just keep saving into
investments and then just hey i'm never
going to sell them yeah it's it's i
think there's two types of people
there's entrepreneurs and there's um w-2
workers as an entrepreneur my goal is to
build a machine that is an asset that
can create capital and cash and once you
have that machine you feed it as
necessary and it continues to create
what you can and a media brand is that a
business is that it can be whatever um
but yeah i have what i need to live on
and the rest of it gets
invested the best that i can into
different buckets equities cash and
the majority of my net worth is in my uh
real estate portfolio
and uh on crypto talk to me about that
like what you say you don't understand
it uh what do you think about it do you
think it it's viable is it more of like
a lottery ticket in your opinion in
terms of maybe it works maybe it doesn't
yeah i don't think
jeff booth and this uh the price of
tomorrow in the deflationary environment
i don't think that those people
understand this big aspect of our
service economy and how much work it's
going to be to actually for humans to
maintain and build our world and that
technology advancing can only do so much
to decrease the cost of everything some
people believe that technology is going
to take over the world it's going to do
everything and humans won't really have
a role
that in that case a deflationary
environment where you use something like
bitcoin to spend and earn and buy
works but
if your currency is getting more and
more valuable and everything else is
getting cheaper in relation i don't
think it encourages spending and growth
and people to enjoy their lives so i
look at it as a
store of value and uh and it's it's
definitely something really serious that
i
i know great things will come from it um
i don't know what they'll be so yeah and
uh you just have bitcoin or you have
other cryptocurrencies as well i don't
have much bitcoin a little and then
ethereum and solana i'm a solana fan
because i've i've toured around with
some nft projects and some crypto
projects and it's it's
it's a great learning experience what
did you do with the nfts you just saw a
lot of these in it you're like oh yeah
you sold a lot of them the tomato the
tomato meme has just been something that
follows me around twitter and people
everything i write they comment on it
about tomatoes and understanding scale
right so um we built we did a tomato
token crypto on ethereum we learned a
lot about ethereum it was a f it was a
yielding coin so we learned a lot about
that it was a massive failure because
nobody understood the yield part of it
and staking is kind of complex for for
me and my crowd um and then we built a
uh bromato
nft project where there's four thousand
some of them that we're pulling up now
yeah four thousand bermatos we had an
artist uh a really cool artist that
we're gonna
disclose after we finish all the all the
other projects that we're gonna do with
it but
i looked at it and said hey i'm a i'm an
influential member that's not inside of
crypto i'm not an insider i say a lot of
ignorant things i'm really thankful for
the crypto folks on twitter that are
patient with me as i learn as i put
these soft you know opinions on online
on twitter and get better and smarter
but yeah we've released a bunch of these
bromatose and we use it as a
philanthropy area and also a community
building tool to get a lot of new people
into solana um going from ethereum to
solana was excellent because the gas
fees it was there's there's no errors
there's the gas views were nothing we
didn't waste hundreds of thousands of
dollars on gas like the constitution dow
was millions drained right
um and it was great man we're building a
fun community and we're gonna release
like female uh we're gonna call them
babemados and then they're gonna spawn
like we're trying to airdrop them like
uh
bro babies like baby tomatoes once a
year as as solana continues to advance
we're going to do more cool things with
this nft product what do people get when
they buy these uh tomatoes
uh right now just
hear me goof off in the discord but i
think it's it's uh
like so 10 we have a 10 royalty so when
they're traded we get 10 of the funds
and that's been 100 sold so far and all
of it half of it is going to buy more
bermuda's that we basically put on ice
and half of it is
buying bromatos that are then auctioned
off on twitter to raise a bunch of money
which was really fun where you know some
big name folks i'm not gonna disclose
have some with the plans of like
auctioning them off to raise a bunch of
money for their favorite charity we've
raised over 50 grand so far
that's been a cool angle and i think
solana has a lot of potential so as it
gets new tools we'll do some fun things
with it can you talk about your strategy
with it like did you just hype it up on
twitter release them all at once like
no so you have to prepare for a mint we
actually had to invest about 20 to 30
thousand dollars to get the project we
had to do all the art we had to get um
you know all the different attributes we
had to build them on the chain and then
we had to build the website and and
actually met them which was just a
little bit of hype but we made them
really cheap like 20 bucks each no gas
again and so we sold them all out for 80
grand in like 32 minutes which was which
was fun i was like that was a success
for us and then the market took over and
it went from point one so i think what's
the floor now point three sold or
something so
people we didn't nobody lost any money
so far so that's that's cool i like i
like it when the people who follow me
don't lose a bunch of money